- We are the cast of "Rebel Moon".
- We did a lot of training in the gym
to prepare for our roles.
- [Ray] We're gonna test which of us
is the strongest in these carnival games.
- Let the games begin.
- Be safe, guys.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna stand behind Ray.
- Here we go.
(mallet banging)
(game beeping)
- Oh, yeah! There it is.
- You're already close to the high score.
- Go again.
(mallet banging)
(game beeping)
- Oh, it came backwards.
- Are you okay?
- Yeah, it was good. It
was good. It was good.
- You got that on camera, right?
- I do all my own stunts here.
(mallet banging)
- Oh.
- Oh! You got the high score.
- What is that? 495?
- That's cool.
- That's all you, baby.
(mallet banging)
- Jeez.
(game beeping)
Oh, here we go. Five even!
- All right, one more.
(mallet banging)
- Jeez. The whole flap
for this thing fell open.
Broke the machine.
- Count it.
- That counts as zero.
That's a zero, you guys.
- Did I break the machine?
(Staz grunting)
(mallet banging)
- Whoa. (laughs)
- You see, it's not hard
until you hit yourself
in the head with the mallet.
(Staz grunting)
(mallet banging)
- Whoa.
- Here we go. That's five-o-something.
- How?
- 495.
- Five.
- Five. That's five.
I hit the five. I hit the five.
- Does it go higher than five?
This is for South Jersey.
(mallet banging)
(game beeping)
Come on, keep going.
No. 455? No. Come on!
- Okay.
(mallet banging)
(game beeping)
- Oh!
Yeah, that hurt my ears.
- No!
- Good work. Good work.
- I take second here.
- You take second, baby.
You got it. You got it.
Wait, wait. Now you go.
- Okay, here we go. Here we go.
Here we go.
- Here we go.
(speed bag hitting)
Oh, nice.
614.
- 614.
- Alright. Nice little shot.
(speed bag hitting)
Okay.
- Think he rocked it.
761?
- What's that hit?
- That hit speed, baby.
Speed.
- Speed, not strength.
You're right.
I broke the machine.
- You broke it.
- Broke the machine.
- You knocked the electricity out.
- I win by default 'cause
I broke the machine.
- Gotta whip that thing.
- Yeah. I gotta get more whip.
- Charlie would've won.
- Charlie would've won?
- Yeah.
- Don't tell Charlie.
- I'm telling him immediately.
(speed bag hitting)
(game ticking)
- That's fast. 834? Dammit!
- That's a warm-up.
That's a warm-up.
- It's a warm-up.
It's a warm-up. It's fine.
- Okay, here we go.
- I'm not competitive at all.
- No. Staz is not.
He's the least competitive of us. (laughs)
I'll go second, he'll go last.
- This is rigged.
This is rigged. No one
wants to see me win.
- Here we go.
(speed bag hitting)
(game ticking)
- Whoo! That was nice. That one's nice.
- No!
- Oh, come on. It's just a mechanic thing.
- It's mechanic.
- It's a mechanic thing.
- So you're hitting...
You guys are doing a hook?
- Yeah, a hook.
- Alright, let's not injure ourselves.
- Here we go. Hit the bottom of the bag.
- Still going?
- Yeah.
- Yup.
(speed bag hitting)
- There we go.
(game ticking)
- Here we go.
- Ah.
- Yeah, all right.
- All right. Last go. Last go.
- I'm having a third go. I don't care.
I'm having a third go.
Say what you want. Edit
it out for all I care.
I'm having a third go.
Sorry.
- Eh.
- You're doing 2-in-1.
(speed bag hitting)
(game ticking)
- No, no, that's not it.
That wasn't it. That wasn't it.
- 834.
- That wasn't it.
- What you made out of?
It wasn't it.
- I'm going again.
Even if you don't...
- I don't care.
- No, no.
- We want one more round.
One more round straight.
- Last round.
I'm gonna try it straight.
- Straight on.
Straight on. That hook,
I think, takes a process.
(speed bag hitting)
There you go. Come on.
(game ticking)
- Come on.
Is that an eight?
- 870, baby.
- 870. There you go.
I needed a straight.
I needed a straight. That's what it was.
- There it is.
- Last one.
- All right, all right.
(speed bag hitting)
- That was nice. That might be nice.
- Oh!
- 797, no!
- So who wins?
- Come on!
- Who wins?
(group yelling)
870. 870 to beat, my boy.
- Okay. Is this counting down?
- It is.
- By the way, the straights
are better than hooks.
Straights are tracking
way better than hooks.
(speed bag hitting)
(game ticking)
(group cheers)
That was fast.
That's gonna win.
- Rock that shit.
- That's the winner.
- Okay, 889!
- That wins.
(group cheers)
Too cool for school.
- It's rigged.
- All right. It's done. It's done. I lose.
- I lose. Charlie's the best.
- It's rigged.
- Turns out Charlie's stronger
than all of us. Whatever.
- I want another one.
Man, screw these guys.
(speed bag hitting)
- Don't look. Don't look. Don't look!
- I'm looking!
- So, watch "Rebel Moon".
- Yeah, watch "Rebel Moon".
- Only on Netflix. Hammer and
punching bag not included.
- He wasn't even technically
in the competition.
So I should win both by default.
- I will take it.
- World champ.
- You like that?
Make eye contact with me.
- Thanks very much.
- Good job. All right.
- Better luck next time.
- All good, all good.
- Good game. Good game.
- See you later.
- That was some bullshit.
(group laughing)
Only on Netflix.